I start with something funny each week and...
...I heard about this teenager, he'd just gotten his driver's permit...
...and he asked his dad if he could borrow the car.
The dad says, "Son, I'll make a deal with you."
"If you bring your grades up, read your Bible every day, and get your haircut,...
...I'll let you borrow the car."
A month later, he came back and asked about the car...
...and the dad said, "Son, you brought your grades up, you've been reading your Bible,...
...but you still haven't gotten your haircut."
The son said, "Well dad, I've been thinking about it,...
...Moses had long hair, Samson had long hair, even Jesus had long hair."
The dad said, "Yes, son and they walked everywhere they went."